let's begin with our
science critic he made a video
a 45-minute video criticizing the
scientific method
and he's entitled to do that the
question is whether he can defend his
his posture
and uh today he talked about in what
we're going to be analyzing today he
talked about time and gps and whether
any of that confirms
you know it first whether it's been
verified and confirmed and second
whether that has
anything to do with physics
aside from the fact that you know the he
might argue that it confirms general
relativity and again does that have
anything to do with physics so let's uh
move on with ours science critic
and this is what he said this is these
are the issues okay and let me set that
up for you here here goes listen
carefully
the questions to be addressed in this
rebuttal are
can it be said in physics that time
flows
and does it make sense in physics to say
that a mathematical concept such as time
is dilated
the rest of those things all make sense
to me like time dilation for example
it's a change in the flow of time
depending on how fast you're going or if
you're in a gravitational well or
something like that and the thing is
time dilation has been measured it's why
gps needs to account for it
okay
so uh the issue is first whether time
flows
can we can we say in physics that time
flows
and does it make any sense to say that
um
time dilates in physics right we're
talking about physics here and then
finally uh you know uh just another
issue is whether gps
confirms that time dilates
and meaning that general relativity is
more or less correct uh or perfectly
correct and whether that has anything to
do with physics so uh what i want to do
is begin with mr brian greene and he's
going to help us make our taste today
okay so this is what brian green said in
one of his um documentaries
uh hollywood movies really okay and here
it is this is the first one
and uh he saw time
first under newton's eyes and as a
flowing river
and then uh he mentions that you know
when einstein came around he turned that
into a frozen river and that means that
you could now more or less
imagine yourself walking towards the
future
on this frozen river okay this frozen
lake
okay um
then um from there he moved on to this
which is the
uh block universe he treated time
as a solid thing meaning that um
you know
we know the future or the future has
already happened and essentially what
you're doing is walking in the footsteps
of what the programmer the designer the
uh
what is it the um
the uh
uh designed for you it's like you know a
cartoon character you cannot deviate
from like bugs bunny you know bugs
cannot work outside the uh script that
was meant already done for him and it's
more or less what uh
what the the
relatives are saying they're saying that
your future's already been determined
all you're doing is walking on footsteps
that are already there and that you
cannot avoid it's like the movie's
already been done and you're just a
little cartoon character in that movie
that's their notion when they talk about
the block universe the question you know
a lot of people raise is what does that
do to free will you know means that we
don't have free will because someone
already designed our future and we're
just
going through the motions
that's more or less the notion we have
here okay um and from there you know
they get to this uh thing where they
turn time
into
uh not a frozen river because again they
go back to the flow and because they
want to show you that gravity is a
warpage of what space time
space time form this grid this canvas
this trampoline
and there are waves along this uh this
medium so they turn it into a medium
this time thingy and they want to
explain with that why or how what would
happen if the sun were to disappear well
they say you know gravity would not
disappear automatically because it would
take time
for the gravity waves along space time
to reach all the way to earth that's the
distance in light uh seconds that we are
from from the sun we're eight minutes
in eight light minutes away from the sun
okay so if the sun were to disappear god
waves as magic wand makes the sun
disappear the earth would not
instantaneously fly away it would take
some time for those gravity waves to
reach the earth and then the earth would
not have any gravitational influence
wouldn't gradually or maybe
instantaneously they're drift away and
this is how they picture it imagine you
know they do want to illustrate it for
you so that you can imagine it so that
you can visualize what they are saying
okay here it is
okay so if the sun disappears the
gravitational disturbance that results
will form a wave that travels across
right
uh the spatial fabric so they turn time
into this fabric in much the same way
that a pebble dropped into a pond makes
ripples that travel across the surface
of the water there you see the earth
running away from the solar system
simply because it has no gravitational
influence because the sun has
disappeared the sun is not weighing down
okay the canvas anymore and those waves
take eight minutes to reach us along
what along space time in other words
what you have to understand from this is
that
they've turned time into a physical
object they're saying it's a medium of
some kind okay that's essentially what
they're saying
and the question is does that make any
sense in physics to say that time is a
physical object that flows
and that can be dilated okay so
this is where we're having a problem
okay with the physical interpretation
and uh so here is
a
a rundown of those two notions
is this time dilation what the
definition says which is the difference
in the elapsed time is measured by two
clocks or is it the physical
interpretation meaning why the earth
doesn't leave the solar system which of
these notions is the real time dilation
and what they've done they merged these
two when you ask them what is time
dilation or you say why does the earth
fly out of the solar system they use the
one on the bottom they say well the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system because time is warped okay time
has warped and you say well that's
irrational uh you know and they bring
all this time dilation stuff all that
thing and you say well what do you mean
by all that well you know you're not
supposed to take the analogy so
literally what we really mean is the
difference in elapsed time as measured
by two clocks well these are two
different notions of time dilation one
is used as a definition saying we take
two measurements and they're different
and the other one says that you know
time prevents the earth from flying out
of the solar system
okay so we have two these two notions
okay
and uh so yeah
unless we can reconcile them somehow uh
all they're doing is covering all bases
they're saying time is both things both
a physical interpretation because it's a
physical object that prevents the earth
from flying out and it's also you know a
measurement of some kind
and so
it's like they're covering both bases
one of them is irrational because it's
to say that time is warped and so they
say well you know you're just taking the
analogy too literally no the issue is
that we need to explain why what causes
what prevents right the earth from
flying out of the solar system you have
to explain that and when they say time
is warped is the explanation
uh well that's not a physical
interpretation because time is not a
physical entity and so the notion that
general relativity has out there is
poppycock it's nonsense uh you can't
sink your teeth into that now if they
want to use it as you know a measurement
of two measurements or whatever
comparison of measurements that's
irrelevant to to physics to science we
want to know why the earth doesn't fly
out of the solar system and they haven't
answered that question general
relativity does not have a theory an
explanation
general relativity has a description a
mathematical description and nothing but
okay and regarding gps well here you
have uh
the notion of gps okay
and uh it's uh
they'll tell you that gps works what
because you know they give you a cause a
mechanism time dilates
well
i don't know about that and he says it
has been measured and verified okay
and so the question is does gps prove
that time is a physical object does gps
prove that time can be warped dilated
kicked around etc
i mean uh what are we talking about are
we talking about uh a uh a measurement
are we talking about the fact that you
know time can be manipulated physically
and uh they give you an analog or they
use these other uh notions or arguments
against you they say your computer
wouldn't work if quantum were wrong you
know just like gps would not work if
general relativity were wrong these are
the types of
issues that they raise against you and
so again does the fact that your
computer works prove that a particle can
be at two places at once that's the
question because that's the theory
that's the explanation they give you and
the same thing with gps they're saying
you know the reason gps works is time
dilates what do you mean by that are you
saying that time is a physical object
that can be bent stretched or whatever
time dilates they use a physical term to
refer to time and they say well you
didn't understand what time dilates
means and they go back to the definition
rather than to the physical
interpretation they just finished giving
you and this is where we have a problem
okay
so uh yeah um
yeah we have a problem with uh with this
fellow's conclusion
uh he just takes it at face value i
guess on the basis of authority and says
yeah it's been proven that gps works
the fact that gps works that's
technology has nothing to do with
science science is about explaining
not about developing gadgets and the
fact that gps works by trial and error
they figured out you know in fact they
did a jeep gravity probe uh one and a
and gravity probe b where they finally
decided where they were going to put the
satellites they determined all that you
know by trial and error they said you
know they took this thing and measured
at different steps what the time
dilation was what the time difference
was and they got a value and they say
okay all we have to do is put it here
and we'll know how much difference there
should be at that level
you know that's technology it's got
nothing to do with the explanation you
have to tell me why what caused each
clock
to travel or to to take at the rate that
it does you know these atomic clocks
what makes them take at this speed up
there and down here at a different speed
what came in contact with the inside of
the clock that's what you got to explain
but to say that it does that's just a
description you haven't explained
anything so you still don't understand
why what causes that to happen all you
know is that it does
and it does does not count as science
it's the cause that
identifying the cause the mechanism is
what is identified as science as physics
okay all these people are doing is stamp
collecting
and someone asked me along the same
lines okay
about an interview i had a little over a
week ago says you mentioned an interview
last episode care to link it are we
going to hear about that one day
well uh i don't think you'll ever hear
about it because i haven't heard about
it okay it's just as simple as that what
happened was this fellow interviewed me
and um he thought i essentially was
going to come and confirm his version of
science
okay that's essentially what what it
amounted to and you know when you
interview someone you believe you know
you think that they're going to listen
to the guy that's gonna propose his
version of how he sees the world that's
not exactly what happened here we
started out more or less like that but
that's not how it ended in fact it ended
quite uh terribly
and that's why he did not upload the
video that's why i don't have a copy of
it he didn't even talk to me anymore i
think he was upset okay and here's a
rundown so that you know what happened
on that day that's all i can give you
because there is no video okay that you
that i can point to or anything like
that okay essentially he was trying to
indoctrinate me instead of interview me
okay he thought i thought like him
and so he was just trying to reinforce
uh what he already believed which also
happened in other um interviews with me
okay people think that i think like they
do and they find out that i don't
and uh so i told them up front what sign
what science was to me that i was
proposing a new version of science
new version of the scientific method
that uh did away with everything we've
done in the last three thousand years
and greeks included okay all of it is
washed aside i dump all that in the
trash can we've never done science on
planet earth okay that's what this site
says you don't have to agree with me
we're not asking you to agree we want
you to listen to understand and reach
your own conclusions okay so i told them
that i had a new version of science my
version of science was rational
explanations now in uh in in that
definition there do you see any
provision for math
and do you see any provisions for
experiments
now he had no problem with the math part
for whatever reason he never really went
into we never went into that in any
depth so he said okay he kind of liked
that but when we went into experiments
we got into a lot of trouble
there was a lot of crying you know
we got into a little bit of uh
interruptions and
you know exchange the words and so on
not that we went off the rails but uh we
didn't see eye to eye obviously and so
what was the issue with experiments
again in a nutshell we also discussed
the issue of knowledge that we're going
to be dealing with today and what was
the issue with uh
with experiments well i said what
experiment can you run and this goes
also for the flat earthers who insist on
experiments
uh electric universers also insist on
experiments you know more than more than
the establishment actually the
establishment likes to do a lot of
so-called theoretical physics they do a
lot of thought experiments and a lot of
these uh
fringe groups they don't like that they
say no we want an experiment to prove to
verify to demonstrate etc etc and i said
experiments have nothing to do with a
scientific method or with science and it
blew his mind what do you mean we need
to verify we need to prove we need to
know
that's how we got into the word
knowledge and i said okay what
experiments do you propose to
detect for invisible intangible entities
what is an experiment an experiment is
see
touch that's what an experiment is see
touch you go to the lab to see into
touch
but now we have all these invisible
intangible entities you cannot see you
cannot touch
what experiment does any of these
fringe groups right
flat earthers electric universes even
the establishment what do they propose
to detect that which you cannot see and
that which you cannot touch
and that's where it comes down to a
little bit of what we're going to be
dealing with today the fact that all
these people say that an object is that
which you can see touch and that which
exists is that which you can see touch
and we're saying none of that all those
definitions those notions are irrational
an object is not that which you can see
or touch
uh existence is not that which you can
see or touch and ask where we run into
trouble and so i said how do you what
experiment do you propose to detect
something which you cannot see or touch
also by the way ratified by the
establishment at cern and slack and
fermilab and all these accelerators they
say we can't see or touch what's in
there
and so they go into concepts it was mass
it was charged with energy so they get
into all they they mediate all these
transactions with abstract mathematical
concepts
and people don't realize that uh
basically layman they think they're
talking about things they think that uh
energy is a thing mass is a thing force
is a thing so when these people say well
the particle of electromagnetism you
know the photon or whatever they say
okay i understand it's a little ball
that's what they're thinking of and they
don't realize that ball really
represents a number what they're doing
is accelerating a number and people
don't catch that okay so i said so so
the establishment also is in accordance
that there are invisible intangible
entities
or at least that there's something
invisible or intangible in that region
that you know they cannot account for
and they just go into concepts
that's what's happening and so i'm
saying what if you have to detect one of
these invisible intangible entities what
experiment are you going to run
and
he did not understand that at all i
guess again because you think a thing is
that which you can see or touch
existence is that which you can see or
touch their synonyms existence and
objects and things and so he had no
answer and at the same time he kind of
brushed it aside because it didn't click
in his brain he didn't know what i was
saying
and so um i continued with that line of
briefing i said how do you define
science in such a way
as to include right
uh those phenomena we cannot see or
touch
and because i said you can define
science any way you want but now you if
you're if you're going to say that
gravity
and say magnetism electricity the
workings of the atom if those are part
of physics
and physics is part of science how do
you define science in order to
incorporate
those uh those phenomena
and he had no answer to that uh he just
went with what we have and he just kept
going back to uh knowledge to truth to
verification to experiments and i
couldn't get him out of that and he just
tried to impose that idea on me he
wasn't really interviewing me at that
point it was just kind of like a
shouting match more or less we didn't
get into shouting but it's like we
interrupted each other constantly and he
finally called it quits and never put
the video up so yeah you won't find
anything out there i don't have a copy
of it he hasn't called me back i think
he was upset at me that i ruined his
show
so that's all i can tell you there's
nothing there okay uh later on i went up
there and uh found out some of his
definitions uh went to his site i hadn't
gone to his site previously but then i
went to the side and found these
definitions and i realized then why we
didn't see eye to eye especially on the
issue of knowledge that we're going to
be dealing with today i told them
knowledge was belief belief was
knowledge and lots of lots of people
have problems with that out there
because they've been
drilled in high school and college that
knowledge is something different than
believe but they don't really know
exactly what it is but they say
knowledge is different
and today we're going to be dealing with
that but you can see his definitions
there and they're not very good in the
case of belief it's the to accept
something that's true where true is
again a belief and what is known as
awareness of some fact where fact is
also an opinion a a a belief and so
these are two words are synonyms and
people don't like me saying that okay
then uh obviously he said reality is
that which exists and the universe is
all that exists
that's like saying god is everything
and again those definitions are
worthless
you can't use those in science
uh again fact and myth uh you can see
there again uh what someone says proven
in the case of fact and myth is what is
a false belief and they're all the same
thing because what the way they really
look at this is that you know what what
i know i know what you know is a belief
that's the way they look at it uh every
person looks at everybody else in the
universe or at least here on planet
earth and says i know what i know but
you what you believe what you think you
know that's the way everybody looks at
this
and uh yeah you find out that he was a
follower of ayn rand and that also
explains a lot because ain't rand uh was
not a philosopher she had no clue about
anything okay i'm gonna talk about her
today i'm gonna try to destroy her in
every possible way i can especially
those people who say or think that and
then i'm saying the same thing that
ain't rand said
and if they say that it's because they
don't understand what this site is about
what i've been saying all these years
okay no
i say absolutely nothing even similar to
ing ran in ran said everything that
every so-called philosopher traditional
philosophers said before she did she
didn't change anything whatsoever
nothing
and i'm saying something different than
all of them and until you understand
that difference well then you're going
to say the same thing you're going to
say dude you're saying the same thing as
a rand
no and so the first thing i want to
mention here is that what i said the
other day that you got to get rid of all
your heroes
you know i had to get rid of heroes and
if you look at the previous uh lecture i
talked about that
you got to get rid of some of these
heroes they're not heroes okay and i had
to get rid of one hero
and that was carl sagan
he was an atheist
and i was an atheist at the time he was
he believed in that we would go to the
stars and i more or less agreed with him
then i thought that we were going to
colonize first the planets and move out
of the solar system conquer one star
maybe once in a star system a planet
somewhere and from there move on to
other stars eventually conquer the
galaxies and eventually conquer the
universe you know that's that's the
train of thought
and um and so i pondered the issue of
whether anyone had already come to earth
you had fondant and his
ideas that you know the pyramids were
built by uh extraterrestrials and so on
at the time and so i was involved in
that i didn't believe in any of that uh
but um you know that subject was very
popular at the time it's less popular i
think today and you know with a with uh
carl sagan on the one side talking about
uh you know
going out there then you give the
possibility that maybe you know the ets
have already come down here or can come
down here you know so you at least
concede the possibility and then you run
into fermi's paradox which all the
all of those you of you who heard about
it you know is that you know i haven't
seen any extraterrestrials here if uh
if you should imagine that or some
civilizations that are much more
advanced than we are so why aren't the
klingons here that's the issue you know
and so yeah i have to delete carl sagan
as a uh as a hero of mine
uh because of two reasons but then carl
sagan was not even a physicist
he he believed in quantum mechanics and
general relativity i don't know if he
was into string theory i never
researched that in his case because i i
can't him a long time ago carl sagan was
not a physicist he was a religious
fanatic in other words an atheist and
these people are more fanatic than
religious folk
and he also believed we were going to
the stars and likewise i can only urge
you to abandon enrand she was not a
philosopher she tried to do physics she
failed at that miserably she didn't do
physics at all and
she was also a religious fanatic she was
an atheist okay and all she did was
politics all she did is recommend how
people should behave and live okay
so that's my take on good ol aim
in some people called her and carl sagan
so and engram was never a hero of mine
but you know i got rid of both of them
yeah i don't think they were
physicists they weren't philosophers
they were just in the case of a ranch it
was just a politician